is that I'm not still watching after
that oh great now we know only the
hardcore brothers are here watching
welcome to round about all I know is
that you there's runabouts na the city
of round about how great the big twist
for the city that always that's the
twist if you can drive through here you
can drive through anywhere Shirley
oh Jesus nice mustache hi there
Manas I would go less spin for that guy
and it's with a twist
Oh Giorgio learned
d-theta like people's small obstacles
nothing could stop George harvest now
people body people things taller than a
limousine look but against everything
else okay Cole sorting well I guess you
passed yes
what a genius idea for a game
goddamnit your job whoa calm down don't
other people pick up my kid
oh jeez Mickey Mickey sorry not Mikey
I've never seen anyone drive like you
just did at the DMV can you show me some
holy [ __ ] he's like the best actor I've
seen in my life this is some [ __ ]
Jack Nicholson shake every cow spinning
things even better how does it explode
so easily guy why does it spin it's
probably a better question oh no not to
people
anything but the out while she asks for
it this is the future of Transportation
whatever you say Mikey there we go
people hey sorry I need something from
my chili con carne Wow kid have you ever
thought of going pro have you ever
thought about not being an actor pick up
the kids oh hi driver I'm sorry my car
is stuck at the stupid mechanic and my
kid is late for school
can you give her right there Thanks can
you do any other expression that we
communicating silently with Georgio's
bread and butter with just a quick look
at the stair on that adorable munchkin
Giorgio knew they needed to make a
detour okay look what if the detour how
the [ __ ] am I gonna get now well shirt
show some [ __ ] restraint Giorgio it
can be too excited in sized panels
school sorry people it's kids need to
learn your explode easier than a madam
crack
only if you give me all your candy how
does the limo race but you're running
into it you morons
you're right literally right I'm not
even doing anything what do they want to
go being a limo driver sure it's nothing
shouldn't be my profession my real
profession should have been I don't know
pyromania kind of [ __ ] you know the
school's baseball field you're the same
guys before yeah so I teach both driving
and baseball you want to make a big deal
about it well only because your mustache
is [ __ ] tremendously amazing Oh God
like I want to go let's spin for that
guy that's how great of a Mustang that's
the power of a mustache okay um all
right yeah I know the school spent all
this money on burning buildings they
can't even put a baseball stadium on
campus priority is am i right
ah funny hey listen up I don't know what
you're doing here put in this town we
played baseball ah chauffeur here even
Giorgio can play better baseball than
you sure
classmates all diseases of baseball but
I always wanted to be a baseball Eric's
the first time for everything
yay [ __ ] love it [ __ ] love it when
I play baseball I bet you'd love it
[ __ ] love it when their people their
bags they babes spec but babies they
[ __ ] love it with welcome yeah cam
yeah
all right first place second babe how
are you not many throwing up
yes balance of all they said how do I do
it
Challenge complete that's my pretty
challenge of all time okay this is what
I do this is my life at this point huh
well I'm having fun excuse me ladies
they see me rollin say lemonade that's
that word [ __ ] car is mate let's go
Giorgio you see this face this is my
face I'm not getting a [ __ ] but let's go
we can save my job
[ __ ] love spinning [ __ ] love
spinning [ __ ] love spinning when I
spend my labor see you [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah whoops sorry
yes this is gonna be the new Minecraft
their wedding going on or some chick
oh my gosh you are just the bee's knees
thank you so much hey I'm only a town
for a little bit but and hey having some
buddies in uniform
take me for a spin around town would be
a pretty groovy bonus right right wait
what what are you doing doc totalbiscuit
what are you doing here we got it
head back to the gym Jesus Christ I'm so
immersed in this story and then and this
spinning a limousine universe what did I
do in my life until at this point I
don't remember anything why are the
people in the middle of the street you
deserve to die I'm sorry this has been
amazingly fun like this video boss
thanks for watching and thanks for being
a bro that's all for me for now as
always gang watch out pouch